people don't give you the credit for the
drums they don't give you the credit for
the acting do you have a chip on your
shoulder and way do you think that's
what led to maybe the drinking oh um no
I don't know that the drinking came you
know I was I could handle it and my
parents were alcoholics but they were
functioning and you know it's it's
hereditary and and you if you poke at it
long enough poke poke poke I got this I
got that and then it attacks you like a
monster and that's what happened to me
but it was you know the combination of
divorce and and my dad died and then it
just kind of went down and then my mom
died and I just hit rock bottom but it's
funny all the years I hung with you I
didn't really see you as an alcoholic a
lot of my friends didn't know even when
I went to reab said what you you know
you're fine and a lot said it was time A
friend of mine a really good friend Neil
Morrow uh he told me when I came out he
said your mom called me and she said I'm
really worried about Johnny I said wow
you know um but it was uh I could stop
right I could stop for a few days and I
could stop for a week and I would always
I would just I would do a gig and and I
would uh stop and then at the end I was
wor I reward myself and then that would
a lot of it too was I was very lonely
and so I found myself if I drank and
carried on like that I I could uh I
would be with these people that I
shouldn't if I was sober I would never
be with a low you would drink by
yourself would you drink by oh you would
when you got the DUI did you think your
life was over did you think like my
career shot everything's done like I'm
no and that's the problem I mean
I I I I went home after that it was
horrible Howard I could have killed
somebody man it was I just makes me sick
to my stomach and I um see myself there
in handcuffs on that's not the kid that
my parents raised my parents were good
and I was disrespecting my childhood
because I was it was beautiful and what
everything I learned from my parents so
I went home and you know what I did I
drank another bottle of wine by myself
holy and then I realiz no and I
realized I was just with Rita Wilson and
all the in Greece and and I realized I
forgot that the next day they said oh
you got to go to Toronto you're in My
Big Fat Greek Wedding too I'm like what
I was ham I I was and I was I don't
remember being on that set so when as
soon as I came back from Toronto The Big
Fat Greek Wedding my sisters were there
and my agents and everybody was like
okay it's time to it wasn't even an
intervention was like we packed your
back you're going I said okay I it's
time were you mad at them no no I knew I
got it so that's when I knew like
man I Fu I'm close was to and I where
did you go to rehab do you ever talk
about that yeah a little bit I went to
cir this place cir in Utah and it was it
was great how long do you go for I went
for 30 days and I just knew it was time
and you know they said well you're sick
and tired of me sick and tired of um so
the rehab did you stop drinking at rehab
I mean did
you the last time since eight years
ago